let's talk about Democrats and the
midterm elections on Tuesday this week
we had a very very interesting defeat of
one of the worst Republican candidates
I've ever seen
Roy Moore in Alabama the Democrat in
that election
Doug Moore won Doug Jones sorry Doug
Jones won and he will be seated sometime
between now and never know probably
sometime between now and the beginning
of the next legislative session in early
January of 2018 the situation in Texas
is very different than in Alabama in
that nobody is talking about Alabama as
maybe a state that could at some point
be flipped blue these were very specific
circumstances a special election a an
accused serial child sex abusers the
Republican candidate very specific
circumstances Texas is different Texas
keeps coming up as a state that might be
able to be moved over to the Democratic
side at least partially at some point in
the next few election cycles and 2018
and Senator Ted Cruz might be the
perfect time to make a run at it
Ted Cruz is really unpopular really
really unpopular and he's also without
question one of the most vile and
appalling and ideologically religious
right Republicans in the Senate and
there seem to be a number of Democrats
thinking about going after Ted Cruz so
on the day of the Alabama special
election Julian Castro the twin brother
of Congressman Joaquin Castro former a
mayor of San Antonio Texas former Trump
administration staffer he took to
Twitter and said be afraid Ted Cruz be
very afraid
matthew Yglesias pointed out on Twitter
that Ted Cruz's approval is lower than
Roy Moore's was before his election lost
to Doug Jones pointing out with some
polling data note that Roy Moore who
just lost and molest children actually
has a higher favorable rating in Alabama
then Ted Cruz has in Texas so similarly
to Alabama a Democrats haven't won a
Senate race in Texas for a very long
time and is it Beto or Beto Oh
I don't know how he pronounces the name
Beto O'Rourke is Ronnie I'll go with
that is running against Ted Cruz and
he's raised a nearly three million
dollars so far Ted Cruz truly one of the
worst stains on American politics and it
would be tremendous to see him out stood
but it is going to be tough and this is
where the conversation about how to use
limited resources comes up and we get
questions all the time that about
primary moderate Democrats corporate
Democrats versus trying to flip red
seats to blue do you put more money into
trying to get rid of this really
horrible senator in a red state of Texas
or do you spread that money in some
purple states where you might be able to
flip a couple of seats although they
wouldn't be as ideologically disgusting
people it's it's it's a zero-sum thing
you only have limited resources you've
got to figure it out and I do think that
you can flip this one too especially
because Ted Cruz isn't in it for Texas
he's in it for his own career and for
Jesus he ran it for president in the
first few years of his term freshman
senator right yeah and I guess you can
levy the same charge against Obama but
the difference is Obama won yes and
Obama is not I can't think of any way in
which Obama is like Ted Cruz I was going
to try to find one particular difference
and then I realized it's pointless I
came in both human being I can't find
any similarity other than they're both
homosapiens yeah and and and appear to
be male although there are people who
have called that into question about
President Obama you should see the
websites where it happens
these are shaping up to be really
interesting midterms the typical first
midterm after a new president election
tends to be bad for the party in the
White House didn't happen under george w
bush the republican party in 2002
actually picked up seats in the House
and Senate but it was a very unusual and
unique situation being I I would argue a
related to 9/11 in many ways Obama lost
big in 2010 and that's typically what
happens in the Trump era anything could
happen
there could be gigantic losses for
Republicans or maybe not yeah but I
think Democrats have to defend
themselves in 10 red states for the
Senate so it's gonna be really hard for
them to recapture the Senate
I was looking at the numbers and of the
33 Senate races that are happening in
2018 I believe 25 or 26 are Democrats so
number one Democrats in general have way
more Senate seats to defend then do
Republicans and there are a lot of
borderline states there where Democrats
need to defend seats or like red ones
nor red well or Hannah Missouri too so
even with Donald Trump with a 30
whatever percent approval rating it
could be very difficult actually for
Democrats to make headway in the Senate
send me your thoughts
what should Democrats focus on in the
2018 midterms I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's sponsor is hello
fresh hello fresh is a meal kit delivery
service which does the shopping the
planning and the delivery of great
step-by-step recipes with pre measured
ingredients so you can just cook eat and
enjoy all the ingredients are delivered
right to your door in recyclable
insulated packaging they come with
pre-measured handy labeled meal kits so
you know exactly which ingredients go
with which recipe and they've got a wide
variety of really great chef curated
recipes which change weekly you've got
the classic plan which has a variety of
meat fish and seasonal produce you've
got the veggie plan which comes with
vegetarian recipes and plant-based
proteins and you've got the family plan
which is the quick and easy meals for
the entire family and better yet you can
also choose a delivery day that works
for your particular schedule you can
also pause the account for weeks at a
time I think that this is so great
because for under ten bucks a meal you
don't have to spend that time consuming
part of your weekend or week planning
meals or grocery shopping you can also
avoid spending money on takeout to have
an easy night and you also don't have to
worry about making sure that you've got
all the right ingredients left on the
day that you're finally going to cook
the recipe I highly recommend you check
out hellofresh and get $30 off of your
first week by going to hellofresh comm
and entering the promo code
Pakman 30 once again to save $30 off of
your first week of hellofresh
go to hellofresh comm and put in the
promo code PA k ma n 3-0